Will you marry me?
I want us to be there
for each other.
Oh my God, I'm shaking.
I'm definitely gonna cry.
You see, Your Majesty,
it was love at first sight.
It was not, Your Majesty.
The young lady flatters me.
But it was not
love at first sight.
For either of us.
There was attraction,
certainly.
At least on my part.
But Miss Bridgerton
thought me presumptuous,
arrogant, insincere.
All fair, really.
And I thought her
a prim young lady
barely out
of leading strings
Not to mention the sister
of my best friend.
So romance was entirely
out of the question
for both of us.
But in so removing it,
we found something
far greater.
We found friendship.
You see, Miss Bridgerton
and I have been fooling
all of Mayfair
for quite some time.
We have fooled them into
thinking we are courting.
When really, all along...
we simply enjoyed
each other's company so much
we could not stay away
from one another.
I've never been a man
that much enjoyed flirting
or chatting,
or indeed talking at all.
But with Daphne,
Miss Birdgerton,
conversation
has always been easy.
Her laughter brings me joy.
To meet a beautiful woman
is one thing.
But to meet your best friend
in the most beautiful
of women
is something entirely apart.
And it is with
my sincerest apologies
I must say it took
the Prince coming along
for me to realise
I did not want
Miss Bridgerton
to only be my friend,
I wanted her to be my wife.
I want her to be my wife.
And so I plead with you...
not to make us wait.
You know, I was thinking…
What's that?
Let's get married.
Don't we need like a...
like a preacher
or something?
What about the rings?
What about rings?
I mean,
for future reference,
I like princess cut.
-I like emerald cut.
-I've got an idea.
Never pear-shape.
Princess cut!
My favourite.
I give you this sweaty piece
of my father's bandana,
as a token of my love.
It's perfect.
Yeah.
By the power vested in me,
by the sky, the stars
and the sea,
I now pronounce us
husband and wife.
Through sickness and health.
For richer and poorer.
Until death do us part.
You may kiss your bride.
Can we get a dog?
OK, Sarah,
let's just get home first.
-Let's get a dog.
-OK.
I want you to have this.
A can of beans?
Just pretend it's corn,
it's a very long story.
You have taught me...
that...
love hurts.
You've taught me
that life...
It hurts.
And I want to be
there for you.
I want us to be
there for each other.
So that maybe...
it hurts a little less.
Alex Pearl Vause?
Yes,
Piper Elizabeth Chapman.
Will you be my partner...
through love...
and through pain...
and through beauty fish...
forever?
Is that your question?
Alex, will you marry me?
I figured that's
what you were doing.
And...
Yes.
Hurrah!
Bravo.
Bravo!
Do you have to do this now?
I mean, I guess...
timing has never been
either of our strong suits.
I kind of think that I did.
And you did just say yes!
That is what I said,
isn't it?
His Royal Highness
the Prince of Wales,
Your Majesty.
Thank you.
It’s done.
I did it.
Where?
In the nursery.
The nursery?
Hardly the most
romantic setting.
Did you get on one knee?
No, I didn’t.
But I'm surprised
by the question.
Why?
I thought in terms of rank
the Prince of Wales
only ever knelt
before the Sovereign.
He didn't say that.
What did you say?
I said it's a proposal
of marriage dear,
not a show of strength.
After all that,
did she at least accept?
Yes.
What did she say?
Please.
And that it was the happiest
moment of her life.
-Congratulations.
-Then what?
I sent her back to London.
Boy you turn me...
Where does she live?
In Earl's Court,
in a flat she shares with--
Prostitutes and Australians.
What?
Isn't that who lives
in Earl's Court?
In a flat she shares
with friends.
Amy?
Will you marry me?
One moment, please.
Really, you're going
to answer that right now?
It's Leonard,
I don't want to be rude.
-Hello?
-Oh hey, where you been?
We've been calling you
for hours.
Oh I'm sorry, my phone
was on airplane mode.
Why?
Because I was
on an airplane.
Hey, put him on speaker.
Hey, where are you?
I came to Princeton
to see Amy.
It's a funny story,
actually.
I was having lunch
with Dr Nowitzki,
and she kissed me.
-Excuse me?
-What?
I'm sorry?
And in that moment
I realised
that Amy was the only woman
I ever wanted to kiss
for the rest of my life.
So I came to New Jersey
to ask her to marry me.
That's so sweet!
Sheldon!
Although there was one man
whose blessing I needed
first.
I've thought about it,
and I really want
to spend the rest of my life
with Amy.
Do I have your blessing?
Well, Sheldon.
I think you should
make her finger like Saturn
and put a ring on it.
You asked Stephen Hawking
and not her father?
Stephen Hawking's a genius.
If he said no,
I wasn't going to waste
my time on her father.
But you did ask my father?
I did. He said yes.
Although not
in a robot voice
so it wasn't nearly as cool.
OK, oh my God,
I can't believe
you guys are engaged!
We're not engaged yet.
She's taking forever
to answer.
Because you're on the phone!
We'll call you back.
-She said yes.
-Congratulations!
You might want to read
the inscription
on that there belt.
Why?
Oh no, what does it say?
"Amy Santiago,
will you marry me?"
Surprise.
I'm so confused.
I don't know
what's happening right now.
I'm so confused,
I don't know
what's happening right now
title of your sex tape.
Oh my God, I'm shaking.
I'm definitely gonna to cry
title of your sex tape.
Wait, is this
really happening?
Is this part of the heist?
If this is part of the heist
I will dump you so hard.
No, please Ames.
Look, it's really happening,
OK?
It's not part of the heist,
I promise. This is real.
-It is?
-Yeah.
OK, here goes.
Ames, I love you.
I love how smart you are,
I love
how beautiful you are,
I love your face
and I love your butt.
I should have written
this down first.
No, no it's OK, go on.
I love how much you pretend
to like Die Hard.
I like the second one.
-You don't have to.
-OK.
Yeah, you're kind
and you're funny
and you're the best person
I know
and...
the best detective.
Also for reals,
I love your butt.
-I love yours too.
-Gross.
Amy Santiago,
will you marry me?
Jake Peralta,
I will marry you.
I love you so much.
Hey, jerkos!
This little tramp escaped
so that ought to teach...
-Did you just?
-Mm-hmm.
-And did you say?